what does black widow do like you know
she's not working at the gap part-time
i don't know that how
do superheroes in the mcu earn a
paycheck
nina well no you know what i'm going to
i'm going to toss this one to tom first
tom if you're sure yeah
yeah okay so the way that i see it there
are three
different ranks of superheroes in the
mcu right you've got your a-listers your
b-listers and your c-listers
does that seem accurate okay yeah so at
the uh
at the bottom rung i think what you've
got is uh
you've got guys like white vision you've
got
the ones that nobody's like super
familiar with but they all know
he's around i think those guys are
mostly doing grubhub
okay so after that they're just
postmates delivery drivers
100 yeah no they've got jet packs
they've got flight they've got yeah
motorcycles and stuff like they can they
do okay like they're they're probably
pulling like 30 percent more deliveries
than your average driver so they're like
they're making more than the minimum
wage
but at the same time it's like it's
always weird because they show up in the
door and they're like yeah
yes yeah
okay so b listers i think uh though
those are the guys that are gonna like
so you've got like uh like war machine
guys like that uh they're all doing
cameo
uh and they're all right
they're they're like it keeps them busy
it's like really like it's more
comfortable than most people have any
right to be you work two days a week
you know you you pump out like 17 or 18
of these things a day
you're living you're fine you're you're
doing okay now
there are also the a-listers but before
i get to that i think that there's
there's an in-between with the b-listers
and the
list just that i think uh we need to
address and that's hawkeye
i think hawkeye tells everybody that he
and this is just based on his haircut
from endgame
i think he tells everybody that he's
doing really well trading bitcoin
yeah in reality he's on cameo too
and he's charging hudson
or he's like selling like his belongings
on ebay
there's probably like a little bit of
like memorabilia stuff
yeah this was in the same room as
captain america yeah this was in the
same room
this is something i stole off iron man
suit exactly yeah no that's that's what
it is he's going through
blockers when they're not at work and
he's like
yeah who wants loki's tic-tacs
i found them like they were on the
ground close to where loki was also on
the ground
so there's an argument to be made that
these are 500 tick tacks
uh so i think that that's what he's
doing and then a-listers was like that
was really a that was a problem for me
like i was i was trying to figure it out
um
and then i remembered there's that line
in
it's in uh in captain america and the
winter soldier
uh where where captain america gets into
the elevator
and then all the guys piling after him
and captain america says
before we start uh does anybody want to
hear about me undies
they're all natural and they're three
times
as absorbent as cotton me undies
the underpants that a postal worker has
to hand to you so yes
i think
i think it's endorsements i think that
the a-listers are all
and we see like a little bit of it with
like with captain america in homecoming
where he has to do like that he's doing
the public service announcements like
there's no way that he's not making at
least scale doing that right
i mean we can agree that's those are my
theories
okay very good now we should before we
continue we should establish why we're
even asking this question right because
in falcon and the winter
soldier anthony mackie's character sam
wilson
the falcon the new captain america goes
to a bank
and like the human torch from anchorman
was denied a bank loan
he says the bank officer is like well
aren't you does stark give you money
what do you
how and he's like it doesn't really work
that way and he says i got government
contracts
but and then he kind of trails off
and so that's kind of that's what got us
thinking about what like
okay so if you're on the avengers how
like how do you make money you know
right like
what happens nina did you have any
thoughts about this
well another nearly as uh as clever as
tom's ranking of uh
you know postmates delivery to uh
podcast endorsements
i mean there's the obvious standard
there's the obvious ones with like you
know we know how tony stark made his
money right he ran stark enterprises
i know he stopped selling weapons but he
is like this tech wiz who can create and
sell
basically anything in the world so there
there's that um
i and i got the sense that like captain
america's through time are like
subsidized by the us
government especially as we got into
falcon the winter soldier
but yeah i like i really struggled with
like what does black widow do like you
know she's not working at the gap
part-time um
i don't know and so it's just she might
she's undercover
maybe she folds khakis you know i have
no idea but yeah because it's like these
are some of the most recognizable people
in the world so how would they hold like
a regular
job and also most regular jobs don't let
you leave for weeks at a time to go like
squash a hydra
uprising in some far-flung european
country
right right most jobs aren't like yeah
you can have a month off to go fight
thanos
right because like with with black widow
specifically you brought up black widow
we
saw at the beginning of avengers and in
iron man
uh that she worked for shield and so
obviously she was writing a paycheck
that way but then in
captain america and the winter soldier
shield
disbands and so she's obviously not
going to earn a paycheck that way
after that so yeah you raise a good
question how is she paying the rent i
mean maybe we'll find out right black
widow movie but
it seems unlikely that they're going to
cover particular so either
like every kind of non-subsidized person
has some enormous family inheritance
that they're just still working through
or how but like that's unlikely i mean
and i guess the only other one where i'm
like i know how he has a brownstone in
new york is doctor strange because he
was a neurosurgeon and that's a very
high paying job
and plus that was just like a place that
the that the wizards all owned anyways
oh that's true but i mean they're like
free right
but even magic
oh man i forgot about magic okay yeah
yeah yeah
the cop-out magic yeah i'm just like
i don't understand where the paychecks
come from for anyone like war machine or
black widow
or i guess and is ant-man does scott
lang just kind of work for hank pym
is that ant-man he's got the security
system
that's right he's a small business owner
that's right he's a small business owner
so he has like a legit way to make a
living
mm-hmm yeah because money was a central
focus in the first ant-man he was
arrested right uh a burglar
so he he was his mother right because he
had gone to jail for like some huge
heist right and then he was like i want
to
keep stealing to support my family yeah
and so when you make that a prime
concern of your of your story it's it's
you know you can have some fun
explaining how and why he needs and gets
money
right but yeah it's still it's still you
know
i have my own theories right because
there is brian well we started i'm so
glad that you asked
uh we started talking about this because
of falcon in the winter soldier and then
i got to thinking well what about wanda
vision right
so in infinity war we see that
wanda and vision are hanging out in
edinburgh
scotland in some very fancy looking
apartment or hotel who's paying for that
i don't know then at the end of
wandavision
spoilers we find out that there was a
deed to a house
owned by wanda and it literally said on
the deed
vision so legally
this robot owned this land
that they somehow bought and paid for
right and we're going to build a house
on so this raises a lot of questions
because
because vision doesn't yes i have one
thing
so you're talking about the scene in one
division where uh she they flash back to
the uh what is grief but not love
persevering that was that not a fancy
hotel that was the uh avengers
headquarters she says
no no no no no right right no yes you
are correct this is at the beginning of
infinity war that you're
oh i'm talking about the beginning of
infinity war that's right they're in uh
scotland just
hanging out that's right right right she
shows up and she figures out the vision
that has learned how to turn himself
into paul bettany which is
right awesome seemed to work out well
for both of them
um so but so it raises the question like
how does this robot who is not
a person how does he have money
to go in on a house right with wanda
maximoff
who also doesn't have a job if we're
just talking in terms of like universe
building i would say that this is the
beginning of a giant
mcu real estate bubble crash this is
another like 2008 all over again where
what happens is the banks start
giving out loans to beings
that are not necessarily going to be
considered legally human in the future
like they know that there's going to be
a court case coming up
and then they've got their people behind
the scenes pushing for you know what man
i mean are synthesized really human
beings
he's 90 vibranium i mean that's a i
don't know
i'm not so like could he even really own
the house that he's been paying for this
entire time
right what what person is like i'll
definitely sell a house to you
well this is i mean this helps to
explain why they wouldn't give falcon
alone
after the blip right because that house
is bought pre-blip
right and then everyone goes away and
they're like
we're not just giving out houses to
avengers anymore
um but but but but but this raises the
question this is so how are they paying
for this thing in the first place how
are they even getting these loans where
is the where's the down payment coming
from
and the only thing i could think of the
only way that i think that wanda
maximoff
and the vision make money is through
mind control there's they don't do
anything that makes perfect sense
they don't do any work for goods or
services
outside of being superheroes and we know
now
that stark doesn't pay them so they must
go
to uh when they need sweaters they go to
jcpenney
they take what they want yeah and they
do a little jedi mind trick
you know you don't need to see my credit
card and then they leave right
ultimately you got vision like uh he's
messing with bank accounts digitally
yeah right that's a small and
untraceable crime
what crime is justifiable for a
superhero to commit
there's a whole book to be written here
you guys yeah
nobody's going to buy it yeah it's a
really good book
you can steal bread to feed your family
that's justifiable but what if instead
of bread
your family needs a really fancy hotel
in scotland
to just like not be an avenger right
or to buy a house in new jersey sorry
new jersey
we stole this land who owned that parcel
of land they lost
all that money because wanda did her
little
whoop you know the thing the mind
control thing mind control
and vision too can like unlock and
re-lock your memories in your brain
apparently mm-hmm
so straight up mind control that's brian
i love that you've cast this robot god
as the jean version of the franchise
yeah yeah yeah just trying to get by
yeah just trying to get by baby just
needs that loaf of bread
hotel room for his loved ones just this
bulletproof man who can walk through
any wall on the planet he's just trying
to get by
what is love if not stealing mind
control
and in new jersey through mind control
persevering
yeah it's pretty sad when you think
about it were they sneaking into those
hotel rooms
is that what was happening i think they
went to the front desk and they were
like
you have a reservation for wanda
maximoff and the vision
right and they're like yes
because they did mind control there's no
other explanation
and also the hotel in scotland as hotels
i want to do would be like can i see
your passport and they'd be like no
because we're
like not real people so they would have
to use mind control
i'm a former terrorist he's a robot
we're kind of on the run
sokovia accords i don't know yada yada
anyway can we have a master suite yeah
they'll use a fake name to check in just
to like kind of spice it up a little bit
extra
that's yeah man come on
yeah yeah so that's my answer
it's horrifying thanks for joining us
please hit
like and subscribe so you don't miss a
single episode